MIKE: Danielle is sending us
to Zipp's massive collection
of militaria in South Carolina.
MIKE: Oh, my gosh...
FRANK: This is it.
MIKE: He's a collector,
he's a historian,
and he's a wild man.
[dog barking]
MIKE: Hey, puppy.
FRANK: Hey, bud.
MIKE: Look at that sign.
FRANK: I know.
Looks pretty mellow.
[dog whining]
[knock on door]
[dog barking]
MIKE: Are you Zipp?
ZIPP: How're you doing?
That's me.
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
Nice to meet you.
Can we look around
a little bit?
ZIPP: Yeah.
MIKE: So do you
specialize in vehicles?
I saw, when we
came down the road,
you got a bunch of Jeeps
and trucks and everything.
ZIPP: Yeah, rent them out
to production companies
and all like that-- this,
that was in Forrest Gump...
MIKE: That was in Forrest Gump?
ZIPP: Yes, it was.
I had a 151 Army Jeep
that was in Dennis Hopper's
film Chasers.
MIKE: So this was
in a Hopper movie,
this was in Forrest Gump.
ZIPP: Yeah.
MIKE: Zipp was smart
to do the prop rental.
One, it was showcasing
his collection;
and two, he was making
money from the collection.
MIKE: So, are you
gonna sell this?
ZIPP: Oh yeah, I'm--
yeah, I'll let it go...
MIKE: So your plans
are to sell all the vehicles?
ZIPP: I want to get rid
of all this junk, man.
MIKE: No kiddin'.
ZIPP: I'm just
trying to downsize
my collection and everything.
ZIPP: I'll give you a little
grand tour of some of my stuff.
ZIPP: Let somebody else
pick up the torch, man.
ZIPP: This right here
is a Vietnam-era M151 Army Jeep.
MIKE: Wow.
MIKE: It seems like
around every corner,
we're coming across
historic military vehicles.
And I'm not talking just Jeeps;
I'm talking massive equipment.
MIKE: It's amazing how much of
this stuff you've come across.
ZIPP: You know what--
you know what they call these
in the military?
MIKE: What?
FRANK: Uh, donkey...
ZIPP: Donkey [beep].
MIKE: Yeah.
ZIPP: I mean, I don't
want to say it,
but I'm just saying that's
what they call them.
MIKE & FRANK: You just said it.
ZIPP: Yeah, okay, yeah.
[group laughing]
MIKE: Think of all
the time and energy
that it took to bring all of
this stuff to this property.
ZIPP: I want all this stuff
gone, man, out of here.
MIKE: So why
the change of heart?
ZIPP: I don't have time
to work with it, you know?
My kids are in the military.
MIKE: Danielle said you
served in the military.
ZIPP: Yeah.
MIKE: Hey, God bless you.
ZIPP: I'm retired.
Thank you.
FRANK: His kids
are still serving.
I mean, his whole
family has served.
His dad did; he did.
This has been a family that
served our country from day one.
MIKE: Can we look inside here?
ZIPP: You can look
wherever you want, man.
MIKE: Alright.
ZIPP: Here's something neat.
FRANK: What'd you got?
ZIPP: I've had these since
I was-- way back there.
FRANK: Century of leadership.
ZIPP: The military's
WWII straps.
MIKE: You think these are real,
the Wallace things?
ZIPP: I can guarantee you, man.
I've had those since
I was like a teenager.
MIKE: Oh, no kiddin'.
ZIPP: Yeah, really, man.
FRANK: They've got some age.
FRANK: George Wallace,
he ran for president
four times and didn't make it.
FRANK: Zipp, what are
you thinking on this?
ZIPP: What do you got?
FRANK: Uh...
ZIPP: 'Cause I mean, these
are collector's items.
FRANK: Well, they need
to be cleaned up a little bit
and stuff,
but I mean, how about...
How about $65?
ZIPP: Hm...
Man that's-- I mean...
FRANK: Go ahead, hit me.
ZIPP: Probably about
$1,000 of stuff.
I can go a bill on the whole
box, the whole thing, man,
if you want it.
FRANK: There's probably more
in there than I think, you know.
ZIPP: There is a hell
of a lot more than you think.
FRANK: Alright,
Zipp, let's do 100.
ZIPP: Good.
Thanks, bud.
FRANK: Alright?
No, thank you.
FRANK: I think 100's fair,
there's quite
a few pins in here.
I mean, once it all adds up,
I think I can at least
double my money.
ZIPP: Oh, man.
MIKE: You got it?
FRANK: Yeah.
MIKE: Alright!
ZIPP: I think Mike and Frank
really appreciate
the history of the stuff
and everything.
ZIPP: You're taking
all my play toys.
MIKE: [laughs]
MIKE: We've been on a lot of
properties over the years.
But this one is really
one of the most unique,
and definitely one
of the most historic.
FRANK: See ya later, Zipp!
[honks horn]